what happened
[Music]
oh dear there it goes it's a crisis
that's been building for years
the rising costs of providing child care
now unsustainable for many nurseries
here at cottontails nursery in
warrington they do their best for
children and their families but they're
losing money all the time
do you think this nursery will still be
open in say a year's time as a private
business it makes absolutely zero sense
to continue trading when you've made 50
000 pound loss in this last year alone
right now the recruitment crisis that we
face where we're simply unable to
recruit qualified members of staff due
to the low rates of pay
the fact that we have got
mounting um
fees in regards to gas and electric at a
300 increase over the last three years
and then the significant under
government funding
the prospect of closure would mean
oliver would have no child care his
parents both work full-time and have
limited options we don't have a support
network so oliver is
full-time at nursery so
we couldn't rely on parents so we'd
either have to look for another nursery
or we would have to one of us would have
to really rethink our working patterns
it's a reality facing many parents
across the country
the number of child care providers in
england fell by around 4 000 in the year
leading up to march and as more and more
nurseries close there are fewer options
for parents who suddenly find themselves
without child care
it's a crisis that requires urgent
government action according to industry
leaders funding is the key issue because
the government is the biggest purchaser
of child care in this country so as the
big customer if they're not paying the
going rate there's no way they can
expect providers to deliver high quality
safely and sustainably
government.4 billion pounds spent in
each of the past five years to support
families with child care
but the closure of nurseries is a worry
working parents simply can't afford
becky johnson sky news in warrington